l'église de france évolue le rituel a
été profondément modifiée au cours de
ces dernières années
il se pourrait bien que prochainement
les habits sacerdotaux eux mêmes subi
quelques retouches deux couturiers ont
en tout cas été appelée à l'aide non pas
par l'épiscopat et par le comité
national d'art sacré c'est un comité qui
dépendent du ministère de la culture
mais qui comprend aussi des prêtres
pascal deschamps et dominique thiel une
séance d'habillage comme une autre à
notre dame de paris un dimanche matin
une aube blanche une chasuble rouge
classique mais pour combien de temps
encore à la demande du très sérieux
comité d'art sacré de grands couturiers
ont planché pendant cinq mois sur le
nouveau look des prêtres le résultat le
voici une combinaison de cosmonaute pour
andré courrèges la chasuble
traditionnels pour jean charles de
castelbajac
mais une chasse d'une chasuble
transparente et très coloré un principe
la lumière un modèle le vitrail un jour
un prêtre lors d'une de ces réunions m'a
dit lorsque je suis rentré dans l'église
c'était négliger les 3000 personnes
quand j'avais l'habitude de pratiquer la
messe devant 12 300 personnes et j'ai le
sentiment que j'étais un torero dans
l'arène avec mon habit de lumière mais
j'ai essayé de refaire cet habit de
lumière donc j'ai pas fait un vêtement
cosmonaute est ce que le voyage d'un
voyage intersidéral ou un voyage
spirituel côté fidèle on est inspiré par
la collection d'été en tout cas on n'est
pas contre le changement
pourquoi pas ces jolies colorées et
essaie ça va avec tout vos trois parce
qu'à cause de l'ensemble est dans les
mains des troupes ainsi que celle d'un
jacques aujourd'hui en 86 une robe pour
les presque tout ce qu'il ya entre les
deux mondes comme ça hein qui à la
pointe du jour c'est à dire la mode et
en crète qui complètement ses scratchs
aussi un lien qui est qui est
intéressant s'ils pouvaient se faire je
trouve que ce serait une bonne chose
les vêtements actuelle voulais trouver
un peu mieux maintenant non je dirais
pas ça je pense que certains qui sont
des vêtements très anciens sont très
beau je pense que quand on est devant
notre dame on trouve pas que c'est laid
donc que ces vêtements qui sont anciens
sont beaux mais pourquoi pas aussi avoir
des vêtements plus moderne
alors les soit transparente de
castelbajac supplanteront elle bientôt
les chasubles brodées en attendant les
deux couturiers peuvent toujours se
pencher sur la collection d'hiver